we have this article over the daily mail
i will turn peril into possibility biden
will attack trump with his speech to
congress by saying he
inherited a nation in crisis after the
worst attack on our democracy since the
civil war wow i can't believe he would
say some strong words about a year of
anti-variety and
two billion dollars in damage you know
just the other day or a week or so ago
in oklahoma city
black lives matter stormed the capitol
building yeah so it's good for a joke oh
wait what's
hold on oh he wasn't talking about i'm
being handed a note uh he's talking
about
trump supporters oh he's not biden's not
biden's not talking about stuff he
wasn't yeah that stuff was okay oh that
stuff's okay
yeah i don't know that's that's part of
it those are the good guys dude they're
the guys all dressed in black those are
the good guys yes
really you ever see that you ever said
bit i can't remember who the comedians
was by where they're like
dressed as nazis and then he like looks
down and sees the skull and crossbones
and he goes
are we the baddies oh yeah yeah like
you're using the skull on the crossbones
okay so that's a
the comedy show the name just escaped me
but those two guys
from england hilarious history nerds
yeah totally on point super funny and
they would recreate these world war two
things
and he that moment he looks he goes are
we the baddies
he's got the because they're wearing the
skull and crossbones well so you look at
what's going on now with antifa
smashing and destroying but what's funny
to me is they smash and destroy
starbucks and starbucks is like we're
glad they did this
and in fact thank you for destroying our
bathrooms anybody who wants to come in
and use the bathrooms at any time now
customers otherwise it doesn't matter
anybody you can now use our bathrooms
have you been in a starbucks bathroom
since they did that
i mean no it's like a homelessness but
you know you know what man i'm i'm
i'm kind of chilling uh everything is
like being lit up around me and
people seem to think that there's
potentially going to be a federal
takeover of police but i really don't
think so
how many fbi agents are there there's no
way they can have well there's like 800
thousand to a million cops around the
country
i really don't think the feds can take
that over maybe they can try
or maybe what's really going to happen
is once the police departments go under
then there's no local enforcement laws
become irrelevant to the average person
and then the country just doesn't exist
in a meaningful way anymore what's going
to happen is the talent level of the
police officers is going to degrade
so poorly because no one with any other
options is going to take that job
that the the police may be there but
they will be so ineffective and just
able to be pushed around they'll just
it'll be worthless so federal policing
will become
more how though how what do you mean are
there
so so maybe maybe just seeing like the
singling out the fbi
is a little uh short-sighted because
there's other agencies fps for instance
ice cpp there's not nearly enough
federal law
enforcement to handle the entire country
oh yeah no no red states are immediate
like people in rural areas
like nah yeah so so without local law
enforcement
federal law is going to be wait wait has
there been has there been sounds about a
federal police force
well a lot of people have been chatting
us saying like if the right if the local
cops go the feds step in
or private police hired by the feds oh
well private police
oh i don't know about hired by the feds
but private police has been prophesized
for a long time especially neil
stephenson snow crash
many many many years ago about ghettoed
ghettoed in in the technical sense like
isolated neighborhoods with their own
police departments and known security
departments
etc that's definitely coming anybody
with money is going to be hiring
security so so let's talk about the two
potentials right that's the scary
scenario if they abolish the police and
then bring about their cult
as the local officers we're we are on on
a track that heads towards a
totalitarian
cult organ driving through a town
and then they they stop you and you
don't know why they're stopping you or
what's going on and they throw you in
like a prison never to be heard from
again
because that's their local mm-hmm and
only you can only hope the feds come and
get you out somehow you can't hope the
feds are gonna do anything that's all
you have
to do look at what look at what joe
biden is doing if anything
you're gonna be crossing your fingers
that you make your way through a local
town
that's crazy because if you go through a
red state there's gonna be a guy who's
like
excuse me sir what are you doing here
and you're gonna be like just passing
through and it'll be like okay mind you
keep mine to yourself and have a good
day
it's the feds who are going to be like
what's your excuse me sir pull over i
couldn't help but notice you're a white
man can you give me your pronouns for
your for your citation
what's that you don't oh you're under
arrest then you go to jail
i'm nervous about this because also
because if the local cops do resign
they'll get they're the ones that would
be first in order to get hired by
private companies if they're resigning
though if they're resigning that's
because it's it should be a statement of
position right they don't support the
score look
no no no no that is all i think getting
a bit too
uh too far away from the big picture
here the big picture is
a cop right now can watch
their city being burnt to the ground and
be like i don't care
and then when you literally have cops
getting or getting getting arrested and
charged
and then they'll look at you and be like
sir is that a gun let's see let me check
let me take the bill of rights second
amendment well we don't need that one
you're under arrest
that's amazing to me that they would
that that cops will swear off the
constitution
and then look at it and go uh whatever
guess not meanwhile
they can't arrest the extremists the
charges get dropped the left uses the
fact the charges are being dropped as
evidence they're morally right and the
state is wrong
and they have two billion dollars worth
of damage and only a few cities
over the past year with all the damage
and destruction then you're gonna get
people like juan williams and fox news
saying
cities didn't burn down that's a lie
right people truly people
don't believe that that happened truly
people in washington dc believe that the
boarded
up businesses on january 5th
were because that the maga rioters had
come through the city all summer and
destroyed everything they truly
like honest to god truly believe it to
the point where
i present them with alternative facts as
in i was literally there i saw with my
own eyes
like not hearsay and they're like
whatever it blocked me on facebook like
they just
literally cannot accept the fact that
that was the case you need only
what was it who said this i don't know
if it was like a linsky or marx or
something you need like 11
of the population to adhere maybe it
wasn't those guys maybe it was a
different researcher
you need like 11 of the population to
adhere to an ideology to take over the
entire country
because regular people they will sell
their own mothers like i i genuinely
believe the cops who remain in like
minneapolis
and and these cities are the kind of
people that would sell their mom for a
quick buck
i feel the urge myself to criticize some
of the law enforcement today but i also
feel the urge to defend some of them
there is something to be said for
wanting to try to do your best to make
change from the inside
and yeah you can't you can't make change
from the inside when you're under the
boot of
of corrupt politicians true but there
are
and i know them personally there are
still
good people who are police officers who
are trying to uphold the constitution
who are trying to do the best
but they're being forced into untenable
situation and it soon
soon very soon is going to come a point
in which they have to decide whether or
not
they're going to make a statement by
resigning or it's already happening
or maybe they have to go undercover
in a sense and like subvert their own
views
outwardly in order to be in a position
to make change at some point in time
a sleeper cell if you will throughout
the country
we are seeing the good cops say no i
won't do this
and in many cities many major democrat
urban metros
they're saying you give me a stick i'll
beat my own mom with it i don't care
just give me a paycheck
i'll do whatever you say for money
that's what they're doing you get that
guy on cnn the dc capital cop
oh you know and doing that interview
these these are these are these are look
corrupt people exist
there's a lot of them the good cops in
my opinion have said no and are refusing
to abide by
this insanity and then you have you you
have i guess the banality of evil
in those who are like if we just get
through the storm it'll be okay so i'll
do it they tell me for now but maybe
things will get better
meanwhile the politicians are getting
worse the cases keep happening the
system is being destroyed there's no
justice
why are why why is the system being
propped up at this point i'm just like
we need personal responsibility back we
need the sooner we have personal
responsibility
the sooner communities know that they're
responsible for themselves the better
but it's not going to happen so long as
you have people who want a paycheck who
aren't going to back who aren't going to
back down
well that's never going to change so
what are we going to do you can always
pay people i mean
how we didn't right that's our
revolution was was
was like fought in part by hired guns
vessels yeah
yeah bringing some german hired guns
help us out
so the issue the bigger picture issue
right now is
no community in this country
no willingness to stand up for your
ideals your principles and your your
fellow countrymen
well there are a number of counties
let's say in a local state here nearby
virginia for example who decided to
stand up to their own governor and their
own legislature when they were trying to
pass laws that would infringe on the
second amendment
they put out statements they said we
will not honor these laws we will not
respect these laws
west virginia even passed a resolution
saying these counties in virginia that
wanna
maybe you wanna secede from your blue
psychopath blackface aborting baby
killing
emmer effort northam and virginia maybe
you wanna secede from that state you can
join us in west virginia i think there
are still jurisdictions where you can
find the kind of people that are going
to uphold the constitution and do what
we think is the right thing to do right
i'm talking about the major urban metros
yeah well they're
toast right so i'm not talking about
cops in in
i'm not talking about sheriff's
departments in west virginia it's a
useful distinction
right right i'm talking about in
minneapolis where like they're sitting
there in a burning building going this
is fine
i'm like dude it's the beam get out stop
letting them get
like do these things and so the other
the other big issue is especially with
the federal government with what we saw
with you know
giuliani look what the fbi is doing to
these people some of these bumbling
dotards who like walked through a door
confused and bewildered at the capitol
some people a large portion did storm
their way in and were fighting cops
there's a video i watched from the fbi
where like
a guy grabs a cop's mask and is shaking
his head violently and i'm like that's
messed up
that guy should get arrested don't do
that but there are some people who are
bewildered befuddled and just like walk
through an open door waving a little
american flag while the cops waved to
them and
guided them in the building and the fbi
is like
tell us who these people are we're going
to arrest all of them you ain't seen
nothing yet then antifa shows up and
burns down a bunch of buildings and
they're like that's all right
it's all right it's not all right it's
not all right
the system is completely broken the cult
is taking over and there
and with biden in power as president
going after giuliani oh there it is so
people like to say
i wonder if the reason why many of these
lefties are like through the wars
because they don't want you
they don't want people to realize we're
in one we are in a cold civil war
that cold doesn't mean it's not
happening cold means
it's being it's not being fought with
live ammunition
when the government steps up and starts
arresting or seizing the
the cell phone of the former president's
lawyer like okay dude
this is this is this is this is it was a
but it is being fought with live
animation because when we write
missions cop chop cop chopping aluminum
ammunitions continue
please when history is written about
this they're going to include
ruby ridge in waco texas in the
chronology of this
experience right that is a hot
conflict right well you've also got
antifa
black lives matter and proud boys and
right-wing groups and the clashes
totally so it's taken two to the chest
so as you've talked about i've talked
about plenty it's definitely fourth or
fifth generation warfare this is exactly
what's happening where you've got
disparate decentralized groups
acting in uh in accordance or sort of
incoherence
uh trying to achieve a plausible promise
that can be achieved
they come together they work towards
that promise it works or doesn't then
they dissipate and they come back
together again we saw the network
alliance
this last summer between the
corporations the radical left blm
and antifa we see a little bit of that
splintering
after the election with antifa still
being like f biden we want anarchy all
this stuff but nobody's really paying
too much attention to that part
so the civil war is on man it's on dude
the patriot act basically set the stage
i remember when that got signed and
thinking like this is so ridiculous like
not i didn't laugh but i was like
this is this is so insane that now the
government has the right to just like
bust in my door and throw me in
guantanamo bay
they don't but like i said there are
people who are gonna be
like there's gonna be some you know
federal agent looking at this going man
this is
crazy do you see the thing they just
signed and then
the door opens up hey johnson go beat
the crap out of that guy and throw him
in prison you got a boss but it took
18 years like it wasn't acted on for the
first decade or two obama
what i'm saying is they don't need it
they could go right now to the average
cop and be like brutally beat that
person
and they'll say okay they'll just do it
it it really concerns me that they
legalized that kind of thing
and then they waited like 15 years and
now they're starting to
do these like and going after i gotta
stop
giuliani let me let me stop you again
that's irrelevant
well you you they going after giuliani
is with or without the patriot act
right the point is the political our
culture targets the
the community in this country the
culture in this country has been
shattered a long time ago and now you've
got people saying i don't care
i will enforce whatever you say it's
just easier that way
people wonder why you know just
following orders in in world war ii
journey why would they do it because
man people don't care they literally
don't care
there's no principle behind many of
these people now hold on
a lot of these cops they quit a lot of
them say i don't want to do this
but many of them who remain don't care
and i know there's a lot of them
probably conflicted
but it's not just about the police it's
about federal law enforcement
it's about people in the military who
would would show up and follow whatever
order
because well i don't know what you know
i don't have the information
you know i i've talked i i've lived on a
few different military
bases uh used well just off of use this
and i briefly was crashing in fort
carson because i family was there
and i asked some of the uh lower you
know enlisted guys and men and women
if you were told if you were given the
order to shoot somebody would you do it
and they were like well yeah like
you don't have all the information they
don't give you a pamphlet like
identifying the individual and what's
going on they say
stop that person now you do so it's not
an issue
it's the banality of evil it is not that
individuals are like i'm going to be
evil today
it's their boss comes in and says go
arrest ian they go you got a boss
well they're like wait they're like hold
on sir is this in triplicate
okay it's in triple kid all right i got
it that's like the um the ape
we're like ancestors of apes we're just
these like we're really barely
out of would you say saltwater monkey
bodies yeah basically the animal kingdom
man we're in it we are animal
whether we want to think of ourselves as
like this evolved thinking machine
isn't an animal anymore who thinks of
themselves as that dude i think myself
the top of the food chain that's what i
think
we're communal animals and so we tend to
follow the herd and the pack and we go
where their food is going to be
and so when when they threaten to take
away the money or the food i mean that's
scary
well not only that but you touched on
the real issue
social exile social shame
fear of being excluded fear of becoming
the worst thing possible
a member of the out group because you
will die
alone in the woods that's right don't
want to be the out group doesn't even
matter what the out group is you don't
want to be it bro
and so as long as the cult has
corporate press no matter how much they
lie
people are desperate to follow the
narrative of the of the
you know the dude playing the the pied
piper bro you got to give it to a man
they won they won all the media
all the institutions all the narratives
big tech they big tech corporations the
government the narratives your thought
processes your value system
everything they won they totally won it
will now
take people willing to be part of the
out group
in order to fight back against this and
that willingness to be part of the
outgrouping
involves being financially in the out
group economically in the out group
politically in the out group socially in
the out group
you have to be willing to be a pariah
and an independent
operator in order to withstand what's
happening and
just to survive and maintain your sense
of self and your in your sense of
identity
but to fight back holy crap you need to
be able to amass
resources you need to be able to amass
teammates in a way
that's still outside of the system
you're not going to go
down to your local college like round up
a bunch of guys that are going to see
things the way we do
and most people are going to
duck and say i hope the fire passes
overhead and then
within a few weeks there's a burnt
christmas you imagine they're like
uh you're no longer allowed to have a
bank but you need to pay property taxes
on your house can't pay don't have money
there
don't take your house already yeah then
they seize property so you try and be
outside the system but the system's
still going to come for you
unless you're on some distant planet
which isn't feasible at this stage
unless people start speaking up refusing
to participate in a game in which they
know their opponents are cheating
but instead they're like i don't know
you know i'm good for now
i'll just shut up and just take what i
can get you're right speaking up is key
but also building like the founding
fathers we kind of talked about this
before the show
they they spent two decades writing it
out like creating
it was like a century like organizing a
database and a plan
so in addition to speaking up to have
the basic you know
the technology thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time